[Music]
this
is today's topic sweeter land go ahead
everybody's go ahead and save the title
go ahead nick what is it
uh
yeah putin is that a find the difference
game
yeah putin's on the right
i guess i know that okay so switzerland
abandoned centuries of being neutral and
is now backing ukraine oh [ __ ] that
doesn't happen massive that never
happens because centuries they're like
drug dealers come to our banks
armies you can just pass right through
they were like they were like
it's not just a gold dress it's a blue
dress
we don't care they're like both
they said that their most controversial
controversial thing remember that they
saw both they don't even have they don't
even have reverse or drive in their
transmissions they're like it's a rabbit
in a duck it's an old lady and a young
lady their cars just sit there
they don't move yeah if it rolls the new
space cam was kind of light so so here's
my question though terrible here's my
question is switzerland like now that
they've taken a side do they have an
army are they gonna fight are they just
like i think they're gonna be with you
thoughts and prayers we're gonna send
chocolate to
ukraine
to support the more
i thought you were gonna talk about
cheese like what do we have we have
chocolate and cheese chocolate milk too
and luggages doesn't the fact that
they've been neutral so long isn't that
why their their money is so like stable
because they don't have an army because
they're like we don't fight we bank yeah
and make chocolate well it is because
then that way it's like you're you're
getting all money right it's not just
good money clean money there's a
strategy by them i think they're just
very nice people i don't know man oh you
know what they're gonna supply them with
all the army knives so it's army knives
yeah that's a good one because the
russia is not going to have any more
army knives because they're like there's
a shortage there's a shortcoming all
army knives to ukraine oh the shoes
k-swiss
so they're gonna they're gonna pull up
i've heard that a while huh they're
gonna pull up on the battlefield
and and look at each other and ukraine's
just gonna go
yep
and pull out corkscrews
[Laughter]
according to media that kind of works
against the russian army right now
because i've heard a lot of very um
tilted stories shall we say
the russians were so freaked out they
quit they left the war's over it's over
so switzerland has abandoned its
historic neutral position on global wars
to support ukraine the european country
who famously stayed on the fence during
world war ii against the nazis has
announced it will be supporting economic
and financial sanctions against russia
for invading and declaring war on its
western neighbor damn
uh swiss federal president ignacio
cassius said their move will fall in
line with the rest of the european union
ignacio is a good one
it's not like uh it's a swiss name it's
not like ignac ignacio from like uh
what's the jackpot nacho libra nacho
libre ignacio
it's ignacio with a z i don't know maybe
it's the same so conversations go skiing
in the swift south swiss alps now or no
i don't think so yeah no swiss keys
that's the sanctions so yeah it's one of
them the swiss federal council has
decided today to fully adopt eu
sanctions it is an unparalleled action
of switzerland who has always stayed
neutral before russia's attack is an
attack on freedom an attack on democracy
and attack on the civil population and
an attack on the institutions of a free
country this cannot be accepted
regarding international law this cannot
be accepted politically and this cannot
be accepted morally
that's quite so there you go that's
definitely not neutral sounds like it
was written by the united states
government let's go
so in a way
something that russia's doing is
actually [ __ ] with their money for
once maybe
maybe yeah i don't know what's going on
but
i thought it was pretty weird how like
who was like it's just the military
exercise what are you talking about and
they're like
there's hundreds of thousands of
soldiers on your border what are you
doing it's just a military exercise he's
in ukraine it's a military exercise
they're exercising as a military yeah
it's the weirdest hey dude i saw that
troop build up on the border and i
actually thought he wasn't gonna do [ __ ]
i honestly did i thought it was there to
intimidate people this is true actually
steve told me that he's like dude
they're not going to go to war and then
and then he was right for that day thank
you they actually pulled that one
because they said they said that went
they said what's going to happen on
wednesday and then didn't happen i was
like god damn pretty good oh my thursday
came around
but next wednesday
maybe that's all putin wanted to do he's
like i don't want to buy it into
predictors right i was going to go on
wednesday but i'm not going to [ __ ]
go on wednesday because he said
wednesday
because i'm gonna go on saturday and
surprises that should have been like
sometime in the next year
they're definitely gonna go to war see
that's he needs to make it happen
i can't do it like sometimes in the next
four years yeah see that makes sense
because that's that's why jesus hasn't
come back because everyone keeps saying
he's going to come back
i don't want you [ __ ] mortals to know
me better than i know myself no one
likes that [ __ ] yeah yeah he's like now
i can't come back he wants to be
predictable yeah yeah
jesus jesus is like i'm not trying to be
predictable yeah i'm not coming back he
said like a thief in the night guys
you're not gonna know when i'm coming no
one's
so switzerland sanctions will freeze
assets of listed persons from russia and
also ban people highlighted by the eu's
packet of sanctions from coming to the
country swiss air space will also be
close to all flights coming from russia
except those conducting humanitarian
search or emergency operations
that's that's
that's their playing ball right like
they gotta [ __ ] i just want to know like
how they're being screwed with
monetarily because that's the only all
that morality [ __ ] i highly don't
believe a country i put themselves in a
position
just because of injustice
no dude because why didn't anyone
pressure the us when we went into
afghanistan and iraq wow because our
dollar
supports the dollar but let's look at
this right the key thing is what's
what's known for so it's banking council
is tough army knives and cheese thank
you
you're talking about a world now where
they can freeze your assets and they can
say we're actually gonna suspend you
from participating in in commerce like
the russian oligarchs exactly so they're
literally doing that right now they're
actually like gofundme all these places
are are actually removing russia they're
they're doing that to the rupal they
crashed through like 22 percent like in
20 hours that sucks because it hurts
like average russian citizens did you
see the lines at the at the train
station how they were google pay apple
pay dude they couldn't go to work and
[ __ ] exactly and it's like yeah that's
all putin's fault but put pressure on
him not the average citizens but yeah
but you're gonna starve out all the
regular people that's the intention
right when you put it on his people then
his civil unrest will choke it up but it
never happens bro i wish it did i wish
it did
i mean this this is the game of thrones
right where every single time who
suffers is the peasants in the average
people
and then they're like yeah they'll put
pressure on their leaders but the
leaders are still
it's not like france where they [ __ ]
grabbed all the bourgeoisie and killed
them all it's like all the top people
are still going to be like ads all right
they're getting kind of annoying now i
guess we better do something but they're
still eating their steaks and living
good
yeah it's like he's so brutal that like
peaceful protest doesn't do [ __ ] to him
you know he doesn't really care no he
laughs at it he'll let them suffer
did you see all the um people that were
protesting and and um um all the media
folks that were getting rounded up and
thrown into buses and [ __ ] yeah it's
crazy
in russia yeah
yeah they don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i wonder what snowden's doing out
there he's all like [ __ ] well they are
kind of saving me out here but [ __ ] man
[ __ ] up he basically said he's gonna
stop talking about it because everyone
just thinks he's too controlled to eat
by russia
yeah oh so he said he's gonna stop
talking about it because he tried
talking about a little bit and then
people like you're just a putin lover
and he's like i look i get your argument
so i'm just gonna stay the [ __ ] out of
it you know what's [ __ ] hilarious
throughout all of this so did you know
that uh steven seagal was banned from
ukraine what
he's pro-russia so basically what of
course he is dude
of course steven seagal is he's an
honorary um
like russian military member
he's an honorary weirdo like in every i
bet he's honoring a catholic church he's
an honorary sex offender
no no he's an honorary because he never
was convicted i heard
because you know he um he goes to russia
and hangs out with putin and [ __ ] right
and like it's so [ __ ] hilarious dude
yo what are they talking about
probably his moves
i'm gonna show you a kick he's like look
at that look at that okay that's a crazy
kid and then putin's like yeah you know
i've never seen a kick from anybody else
[Laughter]
it checks out
that's a kid that's a [ __ ] kick
he's like i heard you do taekwondo here
grab my shirt yeah yeah exactly
okay hey pull the gun on me right now
i'm seeing what's going pull it on me
see how i can control it see how i can
control it right now see how i can
control it see how easily i disarm this
guy i just killed him i killed him if i
wanted to
cool
by the way with steven seagal that's
exactly how he demonstrates like that's
every one of his words it's the best
because he's six eight that's why dude
he could do all the little guys because
he's six eight and he's big as [ __ ] yeah
he's [ __ ] 338 right here so he's he's
going to he's going to be he's going to
manhattan he's going to roll on you
are steven seagal and dennis rodman
homies and yes the answer is yes
they're young and young dude did they
all just hang out with like dictators
dictators yeah dennis doesn't like that
as well
you know sean penn was actually in
ukraine and he had to flee it uh yeah
because he's doing like a documentary
right documentary with vice and then he
had to abandon his car and walk across
the border many miles
that just happened
and spagoli went to poland
yeah dude he's getting el chapo i like
shooting on him like that even though
he's a great actor he's a really good
actor he is really good but he will only
be called
that's kind of mean
forever [ __ ] up
anybody who's slightly interested in a
little bit of the history of it uh swiss
reformation in the 16th century
uh was when the neutrality kind of
really began um and then they
they pretty much uh went super neutral
at an international war in 1815 i guess
uh and then since then it was just like
accepted among the amongst the world
that they would always be neutral since
1815 so that's why it's literally been
over two centuries now i think
strategically they were like a good
buffer zone for um right being in the
middle that um if they stayed neutral it
would actually be beneficial for the
rest of europe because if they had a
border or if they sided with one it's
kind of like how like you know nato and
eastern europe if there was a buffer
zone then the soviet union or the the
russia and then you know the nato
nations would be kind of always
not so at each other's throats
that's what the uh
you know switzerland was supposed to be
but i guess now they're like we're
choosing sides now man
why do you think that is and why like
why now i have no idea i wish i knew
like i gotta read into this money dude
that's the only reason we're talking
about always they have something to lose
what made that difference because it's
now they're attacking commerce google
pay google apple pay all that shit's
getting [ __ ] within russia you oh you
don't want to stand with us oh cool we
might cut you off too you're saying this
war comes down
i would to
think that
i thought it was about it's moralism
human rights and spreading democracy
it's about democracy that's what i
forgot just like iraq it's just about
democracy it's always about democracy
understanding and they got it right
libya i got it that's right america it
was about wmds right
[ __ ] yeah america we are the world
police at least we stopped imperialism
thank god now we can just on board you
into nato you have to pay a certain
amount for oh you have to oh by the way
you want to be a nado cool you have to
spend this much on the military oh guess
what we'll provide the quote we'll get
you the weapons you have to provide the
quote it's a franchise it's like
mcdonald's but like military if you if
you ever believed in anything that's
like a good deal that's the number one
thing to believe because that's what's
going on and it's so it's just it's
right there if you want to look at it
but strategically right so
actually the u.s pulled out more
soldiers when the when the [ __ ] happened
went down take a look at it right and
then we only have 3 000-ish
troops around and um one of the theories
is that
if conflict does spill over from ukraine
into let's say romania into finland
countries uh that are close by
it's actually a good strategic method of
having some american soldiers dead so
then now we can legally enter the war
so it's basically tonkin yeah that's the
idea talking pearl harbor
all of these uh different i guess uh
ways where it's like oh we're involved
now
right now they're trying to push that
with like the the flying in the air zone
they want to make sure the us is a
no-fly zone for the for russia yeah
ukraine ukraine's a no-fly zone for
russia so that forces them into yeah
sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah you're right
cool
yeah dude
because then then kind of close well
then it becomes hey if you're coming to
this airspace that you're trying to
attack right now shoot you down that
means exactly so that's what then that's
then we enter the war yep even though we
bombed russian um infantrymen yeah a
couple years ago nobody gave a [ __ ]
russia didn't do anything about it so
you're saying
i'm saying that war is evil once again
but it doesn't matter my guy there it is
[Music]